وفيما يلي محمد نبذه عن السد والاثار ايضا
التي خلفتها عمليات التفجير اذ يقع سد
كخوفكا على نهر دينيبرو في مدينه نوفاك
الاوكرانيه التابعه لمقاطعه خرسون جنوبيه
البلاد
ويهدد تفجير السد بموجه فيضانات عارمه في
مناطق يقطنها الاف الاشخاص وقد بدات
السلطات اجلاءهم اضف الى ذلك تراجع او
ربما التوقف امدادات المياه في المنطقه
وصولا الى شبه جزيره القرم وهذا ما حذر
منه مسؤولون في روسيا التحذيرات من مخاطر
تفجير السد تطال ايضا محطه انتاج الطاقه
الكهربائيه التي تعتبر جزءا من السد والتي
دمرت تماما وفقا للجانب الاوكراني اكثر من
ذلك فان استهداف السد وتراجع مخزون بحيرته
سيلحق اضرارا بمحطه زابوروجيا للطاقه
النوويه القريبه من السد وفقا لخبر في
مجال الطاقه النوويه